Alice Weidel ist bei mir eine der
Bundessprecherin eine der beiden der AFD
Frau Weidel sie haben eben in ihrem
ersten Statement schon gesagt sie sind
extrem stolz auf ihre Partei hier in
Hessen auf den Ausgang dieser Wahl was
genau macht sie so stolz daran ist
natürlich ein Rekordergebnis in Hessen
und Bayern für für uns und ich habe mich
ja eben auch für die vielen Wahlkämpfer
und für den Wahlkampf bedankt sowohl in
Hessen als auch in Bayern sie haben in
beiden Bundesländern ein
Wahlkampf geführt vor allen Dingen auch
unsere Spitzenkandidaten auf die ich
sehr sehr stolz bin und ja also
insgesamt fühlt sich das sehr gut an
aber noch viel besser ist dass wir
deutlich mehr Wähler überzeugen konnten
von unserer freiheitlichen Politik und
auf der anderen Seite haben Sie
natürlich auch das Phänomen bei diesen
Wahlen das ist eine sogenannte
denkzettelwahl gegen die ampelregierung
gewesen ist die ja wirklich nachweist
Politik gegen die eigene Bevölkerung
betreibt was macht man jetzt aber mit so
Ergebnis am Ende könnte es ja sein dass
es eins ohne Wert ist weil die AFD
trotzdem keine Möglichkeit bekommen wird
Regierungsverantwortung in Hessen zu
übernehmen in Bayern genauso
nicht wir haben in der Tat das Phänomen
dieser sogenannten Brandmauer die
aufgezogen wurde von der CDU ich glaube
aber langfristig dass sich die CDU
selbst damit ein Bein stellt weil sie
sich eine wichtige strategische Option
einer Mitte rechts Koalition verbaut das
mag vielleicht jetzt bei diesen Wahlen
noch klappen spätestens im nächsten Jahr
wenn wir die Landtagswahlen haben in
Ostdeutschland wird es nicht mehr
funktionieren und ich glaube auch wenn
da sich die Bundesspitze in der CDU sich
weiter verweigert dass den die
Funktionäre von der Fahne gehen in
Ostdeutschland das lässt sich nicht
durchhalten weil es ja eben auch eine
Ausgrenzung von Millionen von Wählern
ist was ja an sich schon undemokratisch
ist wie sehr hat ihnen also ihrer Partei
jetzt bei diesen beiden Landtagswahlen
in die Karten gespielt sie haben eben
gerade gesagt eine Regierung die an den
Menschen vorbeigeht die Streitereien auf
Bundesebene auch innerhalb der Ampel das
hat natürlich dazu
beigetragen dass die Menschen uns
gewählt haben wir haben uns ganz klar
positioniert als Freiheitliche Partei
eben die die Freiheit der Menschen
bewahren möchte V auch die
unternehmerische Freiheit die
persönliche Freiheit und das was hier
gemacht wird es ist ja eine reinste
Verbots Politik auf allen Politikfeldern
fangen wir an mit dem
verbrennermotorverbot mit dem Verbot von
Kernkraft dann mit dem Verbot von
Heizungen dass sich die Menschen nicht
mehr frei aussuchen können welche
Heizung sie da reinschrauben ganz im
Gegenteil sie müssen sie rausreißen sie
haben Sanierungsbedarf niemand will das
dann will niemand diese Genderpolitik
und die Leute haben die Nase voll von
dieser völlig ungesteuerten
unverantwortlichen unkontrollierten
Migrationspolitik die in
unverantwortlicher Weise ich will es
noch mal betonen hier seit jetzt seit
einem Jahrzehnt betrieben wird ohne
Lösung ohne Fahrplan auf dem Tisch und
das ist eines industriestaates überhaupt
nicht würdig und wir schmieren ja auch
im internationalen Vergleich ab wir sind
nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig unter
anderem auch aufgrund der horrenten
Energiepreise jetzt haben wir eben
darüber gesprochen dass wahrscheinlich
niemand mit ihrer Partei koalieren
möchte wenn das Kind alleine im
Sandkasten sitzt und keins mit ihm
spielen möchte dann müsste sich das Kind
vielleicht auch an die eigene Nase mal
fassen und fragen warum ist das so
gehört das bei ihnen eigentlich auch zum
täglichen Geschäft dass die AFD sich
selbst hinterfragt und darüber nachdenkt
warum mit ihr keiner kohaliieren möchte
ja gut ich meine das ist ja diese
Maßgabe von der all CDU dass keine
Partei rechts von der CDU CSU akzeptabel
ist nun ist sie nun mal da die
Alternative für Deutschland ist jetzt
seit 10 Jahren dort und wir
manifestieren uns ja auch in den in den
Umfragen und natürlich spä wenn es zur
koalitionsverhandlung geht geht es ja
auch immer um Kompromisse und spätestens
dann werden wir
auch uns an einen Verhandlungstisch
setzen und einige Positionen verhandeln
müssen aber ich kann ihn gleich sagen
kernposition der AFD sind für uns
natürlich unverhandelbar Alis Weidel die
kundessprecherin der AFD vielen Dank für
das Gespräch danke schön